h.r 682 the reopened schools act
to encourage local educational agencies
to resume in-person instruction at
elementary
and secondary schools mr speaker i ask
unanimous consent to insert the
text of my amendment in the record along
with any extraneous material
immediately prior to the vote on the
previous question
and here to explain the amendment is
representative ashley henson
of iowa and i yield three minutes uh
without objection
uh general woman is recognized thank you
and i thank the gentleman from
uh texas as well and thank you mr
speaker
i rise today to oppose the previous
question and i do so in support of our
students
our amendment would ensure that students
get back in schools
safely and soon students have been out
of classroom for far
too long and the costs of at home
learning are far greater than we could
have ever
imagined especially when it comes to
mental health for our kids
my bill the reopen schools act would
prioritize state coveted relief grants
for education for schools that are
reopening
it would require schools to offer at
least partial
in-person learning in order to receive
these federal pandemic relief funds
these funds were intended to help
students get back into the classroom
safely taking important precautions
congress
sent states this money so we could
reopen schools safely
and yet this hasn't happened in so many
communities across our country
i am so proud of our home state of iowa
for already taking a stand for students
and requiring
schools to offer an in-person learning
option
but the washington post found that
roughly one-third of all k-12
school districts in the united states
right now are only offering
virtual learning so this means a third
of our classrooms are closed
a third of our school playgrounds are
still roped off
and the cost of this goes well beyond
academics child depression anxiety and
other mental health challenges
are surging the science shows kids need
to be back in school
even the cdc has confirmed schools
is recognized for two additional minutes
thank you
young kids have an extremely low
infection rate right now a low
transmission rate and a low rate of
serious illness from covet 19.
and yet they're forced to stay home and
learn from behind a computer screen
that is if these kids have access to
computers and broadband internet
for many students especially those in
rural iowa virtual learning
is not easy it's not just going
downstairs and
logging onto the family computer it's
sitting in the parking lot of the cedar
rapids public library
logging onto the wi-fi to finish
homework or take a test
so it's no surprise that our most
vulnerable students are the ones who
will
and are suffering the most isolation
lack of social support
added stress and the environmental
strain of this lockdown
have gone on far too long kids and
families are suffering
as a mom of two school age kids this
issue is personal to me
this issue is personal to all parents
it's personal to all families who care
about their kids well-being
kids need to be in school we can get
them back behind a desk instead of in
front of a screen and we can do so
safely
that's exactly why we allocated funds
for this purpose
it's past time for states and local
school districts to stop
hoarding these resources and use them
for their intended purpose
to pay for science-based safety measures
that get students and teachers back in
the classroom
with less risk that's why my bill would
condition
a portion of the 54 billion dollars
congress sent estates for k-12 schools
in december
on reopening their doors one-third of
the education funds provided would be
immediately available right now with the
remaining two thirds available to
schools
in increasing amounts as they move to
reopen
schools with at least 50 percent of
students in person attendance
at least 50 percent of the time would
receive the full amount of funding
parents and students want to return to
the classroom
my bill will help make that happen i
hope my colleagues on both sides of the
aisle will join me
in supporting our students by defeating
the previous question
i urge a no vote thank you mr speaker
and i yield back
yale's back dex a gentleman from texas
research general from new york is
recognized
thank you mr speaker i'll uh reserve
gentlemen from new york research
gentleman from texas is recognized
thank you mr speaker i am prepared to
close and i will yield myself the
balance of our talk
mr speaker republicans agree that
apprenticeships are vital to american
livelihoods
in our national interest we agree that
reforms these programs are necessary and
prudent
it's time to update the apprenticeship
program to better reflect the needs of
employers
and the needs of our nation republicans
stand ready to negotiate
now is the time to give americans
opportunities to succeed and i sincerely
hope that we will do just that to
recover from the pandemic we must also
not through push through policies that
do not address the immediate needs of
the american people
the budget reconciliation resolution
provided for the rule
will drastically increase the deficit
and seek to implement
non-essential partisan policy priorities
without first conducting the necessary
authorization hearings and conducting
the necessary oversight
to ensure that current funding is spent
effectively and efficiently
after the multiple cause free calls for
unity it is disappointing that the first
move that we're seeing from the majority
in this congress
is to employ this partisan procedural
process
i do hope they reconsider and come back
to the negotiating table
through regular order and let me just
also ask again that the speaker
allow members to be briefed by the
appropriate law enforcement agencies as
to exactly what the threats
are here in the nation's capital i think
we would all benefit from that not just
in our work here in washington dc but
also
when we work with constituents and staff
back in our districts
with that i urge a no vote on the
previous question no vote on the rule
and no on the underlying measures i will
yield back the balance
of my time gentleman from texas yields
back the balance of his time gentleman
from new york is recognized
thank you mr speaker i once again just
say that
to those americans who are watching what
we do here
today and over the next several days
they're going to be asking the question
what are you doing in washington that
will help the average
man or woman and child who suffers the
ravages of this disease and the economic
fallout
and when i talk to people in rochester
new york i'm sure when each of us goes
back to our home districts
people aren't asking about the nuance of
legislative procedures
they're asking about what the government
is going to do for them as we face the
greatest
pandemic in a century and the greatest
economic challenge
in nearly a century both at the same
time we have so many other challenges as
well
but the house of representatives is
going to move forward this resolution
does that
it says we will certainly encourage
bipartisan agreements bipartisan
conversations
bipartisan action i think the
president's conversations with members
of the senate yesterday
indicate his willingness to do that but
we cannot wait
we've waited far too long too many
americans have died too many families
have faced the crisis of their lifetimes
because of the inaction
here in washington so we must move ahead
and with that mr speaker
i thank my colleagues for the support of
the rule before us today i urge a yes
vote
on the rule and yes vote on the previous
question i yield back the balance of my
time and i move the previous question on
the resolution
gentleman from new york yields back the
question is on ordering the previous
question on the resolution
those in favor say aye those opposed say
no
in the opinion of the chair of the eyes
have it ah mr speaker i request the a's
and macy's from texas
i request the yeas and nays
pursuing the section three c's of house
resolution eight the yeast and aids are
ordered
procedural clause eight of rule 20
further proceedings on this question
will be postponed
president class 12a rule 1 the chair
declares the house and recess until
approximately
6 30 p.m
you
house will be in order pursuant to
clause
8 of rule 20 the unfinished business is
the vote on the order in the previous
question on house resolution
85 on which the yeas and a's are ordered
the clock will report the title of the
resolution
house calendar number three house
resolution 85
resolution providing for consideration
of the bill h.r 447
to amend the act of august 16 1937
commonly referred to as
the national apprenticeship act and
expand the national apprenticeship
system to include apprenticeships
youth apprenticeships and
pre-apprenticeship registered
under such act to promote the
furtherance of labor standards necessary
to safeguard the welfare
of apprentices and for other purposes
providing for consideration of the
concurrent resolution house concurrent
resolution 11
establishing the congressional budget
for the united states government
for fiscal year 2021 and setting forth
the appropriate budgetary levels for
fiscal years
2022 through 2030 and further purposes
the question is on the order of the
previous question
members will record their vote by
electronic device
so
just
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr flashman of tennessee
pursuant to hres eight i informed the
house that mr fleischman will vote nay
on ordering the previous question as the
member designated by mr
desjarlais of tennessee pursuant to hres
eight
i informed the house that mr desjarlais
will vote nay
on ordering the previous question thank
you
mister thicker blade votes no by proxy
mr freischmann votes no by proxy
for what purpose does this gentleman
seek recognition as the member
designated by mr price of north carolina
pursuant to hrs8
and form the house to mr price will vote
yes he will vote yes
on ordering the previous question as a
member designated by mr carson of
indiana pursuant to hres eight i
informed the house mr carson will vote
yes
he will vote yes on ordering the
previous question
i'm sorry
all right let's see paying attention up
there
for what gentleman from virginia seek
recognition
speaker is the member designated by mr
cohen of tennessee pursuant to hrs eight
i inform the house mr cohen will vote
yes on ordering the previous question
as the member designated by mr moulton
of massachusetts pursuant daytres eight
and former house mr moulton will vote
yes on ordering the previous question
as a member designated by ms baragon of
california pursuant to hs8 hsa
informed the house of mrs baragon will
vote yes when ordering the previous
question
as a member designated by mr lowenthal
of california pursuant to his aid i
informed the house mr along with all
vote yes
on ordering the previous question as the
member designated by mr liu pursuant
dangerous eight i informed the house mr
liu will vote yes
on ordering the previous question
some different characters you can knock
down
for what purpose does gentleman seek
recognition mr speaker as a member
designated by mr
fallon texas pursuant to house
resolution eight
i informed the house that mr fallon will
vote no on ordering the previous
question
uh grab a red card right now for what
purpose gentleman from new york seek
recognition
uh is the member designated by
chairwoman eddie bernice johnson
pursuant to aids res aid to inform the
house that chairwoman johnson
will vote yay on ordering the previous
question as the member designated by
chairwoman zoe lofgren pursuant to hres
eight
informed the house that chairwoman
lofgren will vote yay on ordering the
previous question
the member designated by chairman jerry
nadler pursuant to hres eight
inform the house that chairman nadler
will vote yay on ordering the previous
question
the member designated by chairman greg
meeks
pursuant to hrs8 on former house the
chairman meeks will vote yay
on ordering the previous question as the
member designated by
chairwoman carolyn maloney pursuant to
adress eight
and four in the house that chairwoman
maloney will vote yay on ordering the
previous question
mr fallon votes no by proxy
mr bolton of those eyes by prophecy
[Music]
mr cummington goes high by proxy
mr new goes by proxy
hey
for world purposes gentlemen seek
recognition thank you mr speaker mr
speaker as the member designated by ms
johanna hayes
of connecticut pursuant to house
resolution eight i inform the house that
miss hayes will vote yes on
ordering the previous question mr
speaker as the member
designated by mr john larson of
connecticut pursuant to house resolution
eight
i inform the house that mr larson will
vote yes on ordering the previous
question
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr langevin of rhode island pursuant to
house resolution
eight i inform the house that mr
langevin will vote yes on ordering the
previous questions
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from north carolina seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by miss wilson of florida
pursuing the house res
eight i informed the house ms wilson
will vote yes
on the previous question
[Music]
for what purpose does the general woman
from virginia seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by mr mceachin pursuant to
house resolution eight
i informed the house that mr mckeachen
will vote yes on ordering the previous
question
and as the member designated by miss
porter pursuant to hres eight
i inform the house that ms porter will
vote yes on ordering the previous
questions
[Music]
is
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from missouri seek recognition
as the member designated by mr billy
long of missouri pursuant to house res 8
i informed the house that mr long will
vote uh not nay
on the previous question to hres 85.
it's reasonable i mean at the same time
the art that what i tell you from the
staff level is
the section by section summaries
is
this is
mr president carolina goes high by proxy
mr varsity of indiana goes by prophecy
everything
so what purpose does gentleman from
california seek recognition
pursuant to house resolution eight i
informed the house that congress member
roybal elwood revoked
yes on ordering the previous question
and mr speaker as member designated by
congress member of argus pertus
resolution 8
i informed the house that congress
member vargas will also vote yes on
uttering
the previous question and mr speaker as
member designated by congressmember
napolitano
pursuant to house resolution eight i
inform the house that congress member
napolitano
will vote yes on ordering the previous
question
actually
prophecy
mr harvest outside by proxy
this framework goes by
like
oh
hello
for what purpose does the gentleman from
maryland seek recognition mr
speaker as the member designated by mr
amphume of maryland pursuant to house
resolution eight
i informed the house and mr anfumay will
vote yes on order in the previous
question
[Music]
for what purpose gentleman from
massachusetts seek recognition
as this remember designated by miss
trahan of massachusetts pursuant to h
res eight i informed the house that mr
ham will vote
yes on ordering the previous question
purpose just the gentleman from illinois
seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr grijalva pursuant to hres
eight i informed the house that mr
grijalva will vote
yey on ordering the previous question
and
as the member designated by ms
ocasio-cortez
pursuant to hrs-8 i informed the house
that ms ocasio-cortez
will vote yey on ordering the previous
question
japan and both sides
[Music]
so
high
so
[Music]
is
for what purpose does the general from
california seek recognition
mr speaker is a member designated by mr
desanye
pursuant to hres eight i informed the
house that mr desanie will vote yes on
ordering the previous question
what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr
jones pursuant to hres eight i will for
inform the house that mr jones will vote
yes on ordering the previous question
i am
oh my god
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from massachusetts seek recognition
designated by mr bowman pursuing to
hresa
i informed the house that mr bowman will
vote yes
on ordering the previous question as the
member designated by mr
cooper pursuant to hres 8 i informed the
house that mr cooper will vote yes
on ordering the previous question as the
member designated by ms frankel pursuant
to hres 8 i informed the house that ms
frankel will vote yes
on ordering the previous question as the
member designated by ms
jayapal pursuant to hres eight i
informed the house that ms
jayapal will vote yes on ordering the
previous
question as the member designated by mr
keating pursuant to h.s.a i informed the
house that mr
keating will vote yes on ordering the
previous question
as the member designated by ms custer
pursuant to h res eight i informed the
house that ms custer will vote yes on
ordering the previous question as the
member designated by mr
lynch pursuant to hrese8 i inform the
house that mr lynch
will vote yes on ordering the previous
question
and as the member designated by ms mang
pursuing to hresa
i informed the house that ms mang will
vote yes
on ordering the previous question
[Music]
is that it for the republicans
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr ruiz pursuant to house resolution
eight
i informed the house that mr ruiz will
vote yes on ordering the previous
question
i think it might have been yeah
for what purpose does the gentleman from
michigan seek recognition
the member designated by ms lawrence of
michigan pursuant to atres 8 i informed
the house that ms lawrence
will vote yes on ordering the previous
question
for what purpose does the gentleman from
arizona seek recognition
as the member designated by miss
kirkpatrick pursuant to
hres eight i will inform the house that
mrs kirkpatrick will vote
yes on ordering the previous question
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from pennsylvania seek recognition
as the member designated by
representative houlihan
of pennsylvania pursuant to house res 8.
i informed the house that ms houlihan
will vote yes
on ordering the previous question
[Music]
yes
this man prophecy
mr lynch was died by a prophecy
[Music]
[Music]
hey
yes for what purpose does the general
work from michigan seek recognition
as the member designated by ms axne
pursuant to hres eight
i inform the house that ms axne will
vote yes
on ordering the previous question as the
member designated by miss dingle
pursuant to hres eight i informed the
house that mrs dingle will vote yes
on ordering the previous question
[Music]
is
what purpose does the gentlewoman from
florida seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr hastings of florida pursuant to hres
eight i informed the house that mr
hastings will vote yay on ordering the
previous question
and mr speaker as the member designated
by mr payne of new jersey
pursuant to hra's eight i informed the
house that mr payne will also
vote yay on ordering the previous
question
[Music]
my privacy
for what purpose does the jimmy from
massachusetts seek recognition
as the member designated by mr torres
pursuant to house res eight i informed
the house that mr torres will vote yes
on ordering the previous question
[Music]
roxy
is
[Music]
is
this
purpose does the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
as the member designated by ms sphere
pursuant to hres 8 i inform the house
that ms speer will vote
yes on ordering the previous question
[Music]
just
what purpose does gentleman from uh new
jersey seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss bonnie watson coleman pursuant to h
res 8 i informed the house that miss
watson coleman will vote yes
on ordering the previous question and mr
speaker as the member designated by mr
paul tonko
pursuant to age fresh eight i informed
the house that mr tonko will vote yes on
ordering the previous question
[Music]
what purpose does a gentleman from
california seek recognition
as the member designated by mr gallego
pursuant to hres
eight i informed the house that mr
gallego vote will vote i
on ordering the previous question
as a member designated by mr vicente
gonzalez pursuant to hres eight i
informed the house that mr vicente
gonzalez will vote eye
on ordering the previous question
as the member designated by mr vela
pursuant to hres eight i informed the
house that mr vela will
vote i on ordering the previous question
as the member designated by mr carnes
pursuant to hres eight i informed the
house that mr carnes will vote i
on ordering the previous question
this one
sure
is
all right
so
for what purpose does the gentleman from
texas seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr buchanan of florida pursuant to house
resolution eight
i informed the house that mr buchanan
will vote no
on the previous question
six
so
this
uh
so
so
for what purpose does the general woman
from illinois seek recognition
as the member designated by mr rush
pursuant to h18 i informed the house
that mr russia vote yes
on ordering the previous question
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
virginia seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated
by miss titus of nevada pursuant hres
eight
i inform the house that miss titus will
vote yes
on ordering the previous question
gentleman from pennsylvania seek
recognition
mr speaker
over there
for what purpose does the gen woman from
new york seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr deutsch of florida pursuant to hres8
i inform the house that mr deutsch will
vote yes on ordering the previous
question
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr
cartwright pursuant to hres 8
i will inform the house that mr
cartwright will be voting yes
on the previous on ordering the previous
question
[Music]
so
mr department
purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition thank you mr
speaker as a member designated by mr
gottheimer pursuant to hres 8
i informed the house that mr gottheimer
will vote eye on ordering the previous
question
as the member designated by mr swazi
pursuant to hres eight i
informed the house that mr swazi will
vote i on ordering the previous question
um
for what purpose does the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as a member
designated by mr lawson of florida
pursued the house resolution eight i
informed the house that mr lawson will
vote
yay on the previous question
so
[Music]
so
the most important times
hello
[Music]
mr
on this vote the yays are 219 the nature
207
the previous question is ordered the
question is on the adoption of the
resolution
those in favor say aye those suppose say
no
in the opinion of the chair the eyes
have it
generally for the a's and days
pretend to section three c of house
resolution eight the jason a's are
ordered members will record their votes
by
electronic device
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
texas seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr buchanan of florida and pursuant to
house resolution eight
i informed the house that mr buchanan
will vote no
on adoption of house resolution 85. i
yield back
the gentleman from uh maryland seek
recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
amphumi of maryland pursuing the house
hres eight i informed the house mr
infumay will vote
yes on hres 85.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
texas seek recognition
speaker as a member designated by mr
fallon texas
pursuant to house resolution eight i
informed the house that mr fallon
will vote no on house resolution 85.
what purpose does the gentleman from
pennsylvania seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr cartwright
of pennsylvania pursuant to hres 8 i
will inform the house that mr cartwright
will vote
yes on h res 85
what purpose does the gentleman from
tennessee seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr fleischmann of tennessee pursuant to
hres eight
i informed the house to mr fleischmann
will vote nay on h.res
85. as the member designated by mr
desjarlais of tennessee
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
that mr desjarlais will vote nay
on hres 85. thank you
purpose as the for what purpose does the
gentleman from new york seek recognition
uh is the member designated by
chairwoman eddie bernice johnson
pursuant to hres eight on four in the
house that chairman johnson will vote
yay
on hres 85 as the member designated by
chairwoman zell laughter and facilitates
eight informing the house that
chairwoman lofgren will vote yay
on hres hrest85 the member designated by
chairman jerry nadler pursuant to hres
eight unfolding the house that chairman
nadler will vote yay
on hres 85 the member designated by
chairman gregory meeks pursuant to hres
eight i informed the house that chairman
meeks will vote yay on hres85
it's the member designated by chairwoman
carolyn maloney pursuant to hres eight
on four in the house that
chairwoman maloney will vote yay on hres
85.
this replacement votes now by
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from illinois seek recognition
as the member designated by mr rush
pursuant to hres eight
i informed the house that mr rush will
vote yes on hres 85.
for what purpose does the general woman
from new york seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr deutsch of florida pursuant to hres
eight
i inform the house and mr george will
vote yes on hres 85.
what purpose does the gentleman from
arizona seek recognition
as the member designated by miss
kirkpatrick pursuant to hres
eight i informed the house that mr
patrick will vote
yes on hres 85.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker is mimik designated by
congressmember napolitano
pursuant to house resolution eight i
informed the house that congressman
napolitano with a vote yes on house
resolution
85 and mr speaker
as a member designated by congressmember
roybo ellard pursuant to house
resolution eight
i informed that house is congressmember
roybel ellard will vote yes
on hrs 85.
and mr speaker is member designated by
congress member vargas
pursuant to house resolution eight i
informed the house that congress member
vargas would vote yes
on house resolution 85.
this is protectorate votes i my prophecy
purpose does the gentleman from new
jersey seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss bonnie watson coleman
pursuant to hres eight i informed the
house that miss watson coleman will vote
yes
on hres 85 and mr speaker as the member
designated by mr paul tonko
pursuant to atres eight i inform the
house that mr tonka will vote yes
on hres 85.
mr vargas votes high by privacy
for what purpose does the gentleman from
illinois seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr grijalva pursuant to
hres1 i informed the house that mr guiha
will vote yes
on hres 85 and as the member designated
by miss
ocasio-cortez of new york pursuant to
hrs8 i inform the house that miss
ocasio-cortez
will vote yes on hrs85
for what purpose does the general from
pennsylvania seek recognition
as the member designated by
representative houlihan of pennsylvania
pursuant to house res 8 i inform the
house that rap houlihan
will vote yes on h res 85.
purpose does the general woman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr monder jones pursuant to hres 8 i
will inform the house that mr jones will
vote yes on hres 85
mr speaker is the member designated mr
cohen pursuant to nature as eight
and four in the house mr cohen will vote
yes on h4 is 85.
as a member yesterday with mr moulton
pursuant to hrsa to inform the house
that mr moulton will vote yes on hres 85
as the member designated by ms baragon
pursuant to his aid i informed the house
the ms baragon will vote yes on hres 85
as the member designated by mr lowenthal
pursuing daydreams eight i informed the
house mr lowenthal
will vote yes on hres 85 and as the
member designated by mr liu pursuant to
hr isaiah i inform the house mr liu will
vote yes
on hrs85
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from massachusetts seek recognition
as the member designated by mr bowman
pursuant to hres eight i informed the
house that mr beaumont will vote yes on
h res 85 as the member designated by mr
cooper pursuant to h rsa i informed the
house that mr cooper will vote yes on
hres
85. as the member designated by ms
frankel pursuant to h res
aid i informed the house that ms frankel
will vote yes on hres
85 as the member designated by ms
jayapal
pursuant to hres 8 i inform the house
that ms jayapal will vote yes
on hres 85 as the member designated by
mr
keating pursuant to hres8 i inform the
house that mr keating will vote yes on
hres 85.
as the member designated by ms custer
pursuant to h res 8 i inform the house
that ms custer will vote yes
on hres 85 as the member designated by
mr lynch pursuant to h
8 i informed the house that mr lynch
will vote yes on hres 85
and as the member designated by ms mang
pursuant to hres 8 i informed the house
that ms mang will vote yes
on hres 85
[Music]
is
does the general woman from north
carolina seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
miss wilson of florida
uh pursuant to house res eight i
informed the house that miss wilson will
vote yes
on hrs 85.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
mr rui pursuant
but mr ruiz pursuant to house resolution
eight inform the house that mr ruiz will
vote yes on house resolution 85.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
north carolina seek recognition
as the member designated by mr price of
north carolina
pursuant to hrs8 i informed the house mr
price will vote yes
he will vote yes on hres 85.
as the member designated by mr carson
of indiana pursuant to hres 8 i inform
the house and mr carson will vote yes
he will vote yes on hres 85.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
as a member designated by mr vicente
gonzalez pursuant to hres eight i
informed the house the mr vicente
gonzalez will vote i
on hres 85. as the member does
it by mr carnes pursuant to hres eight i
informed the house that mr carnes will
vote i
on hres 85. as a member designated by mr
vela pursuant to hres
eight i informed the house that mr villa
will vote i on hres 85.
as a member designated by mr gallego
pursuant to h res 8 i informed the house
that mr gallego will vote i on hres 85.
for what purpose does the german from
pennsylvania seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
lawson florida pursuit
the house resolution eight i inform the
house that mrs lawson will
yay on hr resolution eighty-five
[Music]
mr bowman votes high prophecy
for what purpose does the gentleman from
california seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by mr gothheimer pursuant to
atres eight
i will inform the house that mr
gottheimer will vote eye on hres 85.
as a member designated by mr swazi
pursuant to atres 8 i will inform the
house that mr swazi will vote i
on atres 85. thanks
[Music]
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from virginia seek recognition
thank you mr speaker as the member
designated by mr mckeachen pursuant to
hres eight i inform the house that mr
mckeachen will vote yes on atres
85 and as the member designated by ms
porter pursuant to hres 8 i inform the
house that ms porter will vote yes on
hres 850
by privacy
for what purpose is the gentleman from
virginia seek recognition mr speaker
as the member designated by miss titus
of nevada
pursuant to atres eight i inform the
house that miss titus
will vote yes on hres 85.
[Music]
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
from pennsylvania secret
as the member designated by miss spear
pursuant to hpres eight
i informed the house that ms speer will
vote yes on hres 85.
this titus
[Music]
by prophecy
purpose does the gentleman from
massachusetts seek recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
miss trahan
pursuant to hres eight i inform the host
that mrs trahan will vote yes on hres
85.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
michigan seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
ms lawrence of michigan pursuant to hres
eight i inform the house that ms
lawrence
will vote yes on hres 85.
mr hando's highway
for what purpose does the general woman
from california seek recognition
mr speaker as a member designated by mr
desanie pursuing to h res
eight i informed the house that mr
desanie will vote yes
on h res 85.
for what purpose does the gentleman from
connecticut seek recognition
thank you uh mr speaker mr speaker is
the mess member designated by ms johanna
hayes
of connecticut pursuant to house
resolution eight i informed the house
that miss hayes
will vote yes on hres 85
as the member designated by mr john
larson of connecticut pursuant to house
resolution 8
i informed the house that mr larson will
vote yes on house res 85 as the member
designated by mr langevin
of rhode island pursuant to house res 8
i informed the house that mr langevin
will vote yes
on house resolution 85.
for what purpose does the general woman
from missouri seek recognition
mr chairman is the member designated by
mr billy long of missouri pursuit
religion eight i inform the house that
mr long will vote
uh uh nay on house res 85.
what purpose does the german woman from
florida seek recognition
mr speaker as the member designated by
mr payne of new jersey pursuant to hprs8
i inform the house and mr payne will
vote yay
on hres 85 and mr speaker as the member
designated by mr hastings of florida
pursuant to h-res eight
i informed the house that mr hastings
will also vote yay on hs 85.
mr long votes no by privacy
[Music]
mr things votes high and by proxy
mr payne votes i by prophecy
this haze votes high by proxy
mr larson of connecticut votes i by
proxy
lantern votes i play a proxy
okay
uh
here we go this is
for what purpose does the general woman
from michigan seek recognition
as the member designated by ms axne
pursuant to hres 8
i informed the house that ms axne will
vote yes
on hres 85 as the member designated by
mrs dingle
pursuant to h res 8 i inform the house
that mrs dingle will vote yes
on h res 85.
[Music]
you
yes
is actually votes eyed by prophecy
this is dangerous by prophecy
foreign
thank you
oh
let's do it
for what purpose does jeffy from
massachusetts seek recognition
as the member designated by mr torres
pursuant to
house resolution eight i inform the
house that mr torres will vote yes on
house resolution 85.
[Music]
torres of new york votes i by proxy
yes
why
are you
um
cheers
oh
okay
things
okay huh
is
so
foreign
all right
hey
is okay
thank you
okay
she's yeah
this
foreign
does any member who wish to change
on this vote the yays are 216 that nades
are 210
without objection the motion reconsider
is laid on the table
the resolution is adopted without a
objection the motion
to reconsider slate on the table
house resolution 73 is hereby adopted
for what purpose does the gentleman from
utah seek recognition mr speaker i
hereby remove my name as co-sponsor of
h.r 366
the gentleman's request request is
accepted thank you
pursuant to section 5a1b of house
resolution 8
the house dance adjourn until 1pm
tomorrow
you